you practice in Atlanta right that's
exactly right so the rules and the laws
are probably differently and you know
the system is probably different in
every every state it's state to state
that's true yeah but in in pretty much
every state in the nation the rules the
the laws are set to where there's no
preference given uh because in
California they actually try to push the
fathers to be more involved and more
have the kids more and so they push to
have that 50 50 custody if when you say
they who is they the the system the
judge the court you're saying that the
judge the attorneys let's speak let's be
specific because you're speaking in all
these generalities and I want to know
specifically when you say they are
pushing men to have more time with their
kids who is they Court Judge what is it
that's what I've been told from
attorneys that's what you've been told
okay which judge is pushing for fathers
to to to have more attention so
basically what they say is that they
they it really is like my attorney when
I did everything your attorney your one
attorney said but you're just wrong
attorney as well right but I've been
doing this for 20 years
my divorce attorney was one of the top
in San Diego but that's that's what
that's the other point though that
you're saying though that doesn't make
any sense is you're saying that the
judges choose that men okay we went back
to disagreeability what is the guy
supposed to do like so if Adam's gonna
get married and he's going to have
children
you didn't really get to helping him so
like what I mean I think that's why
that's why that's why so many men are
walking away from Marriage exactly it's
because like it doesn't benefit there's
a bad deal it's a bad deal you're saying
how do we fix it and this is what I'm
telling you for an individual man right
now there is no fix now the Lord did not
get married
the laws are changing in Atlanta for
example they are they've just started
this year pushing that it to move away
from the system where fathers or mothers
can get custody because what judges are
doing they're using that discretion to
just basically give mothers custody now
Georgia is moving to a system to where
the default is 50 50. and that's where
we need to be the D if if the if the
judge starts out and says okay here's
what we're going to do you guys are
going to get divorced that's fine
fifty percent of the time with the mom
fifty percent of the time with the dad
now if anybody has any objection to that
I'll listen and if anybody doesn't want
that I'll listen that's how California
is
that's how California is we're talking
about the nation we're not cherry
picking over here that's what I'm trying
to tell you it's not oh my one friend
this or oh this particular thing right
and women women are not only not only
when custody it's like 20 of the time
guys if I may let me get to some stats
and I want to get your opinion on this
so uh
we're going to cover relationships who
to date who not to date divorce all that
we're all over the map here all good
have fun uh so here's some divorce stats
for you guys nationally we're not cherry
picking over here uh here's some stats
for you guys Man vs women women filed
for divorce 70 of the time that goes up
to 90 of the time when they're college
educated beware those SMART Girls y'all
uh women get the kids 90 of the time
this is what she does child support
payment is 720 bucks a month alimony is
around 40 of the guy's income these are
stats and then men are way more likely
to end up getting depressed fat alcohol
drugs and suicidal so back to this this
point that I kind of want to discuss the
divorce rate 70 percent women initiate
this you said this is exactly why men
are so hesitant to get married today so
is marriage an outdated deal for men
what do you think Pearl I mean I think
I think men and women are better
together and like marriage is good as an
institution but I feel like the
government ruined it I just think it's a
bad deal for men the way the laws are
today okay so what should men do if they
want to get married and you believe that
that family unit is is ideal should men
just kind of be clear-eyed going into
this this is why I brought the attorney
you can't handle the truth no I'm saying
like like that's why the legal
um I mean some guys do the prenup some
guys choose to walk away some guys I've
heard of a guy that lives with a girl
that has her pay the rent so she can't
because I guess she can seize your
assets legally if she's just living with
you for a certain amount of time and
that can include like even if she leaves
her stuff at your apartment yeah yeah
and so I've heard I've heard some like
guys have interesting Solutions it was
just a bad deal for men these days
a bad deal for someone who makes the
most money well listen I feel like it's
not even just men or women it's whoever
makes the most money in the relationship
it's why are we pitching holes it's not
true and again the stat that you just
read well they're not gonna okay let me
finish let me finish the the stat that
you just read about women getting
custody 90 of the time yeah right and
this is why it's so good to have a
couple on here that and then they're
both ignorant about these these laws if
that's oh well just men get custody 50
of the time to and it's not true if if
women get primary physical custody 90 of
the time that that should be a a stat
that shocks them right do you think that
they should take a one-year-old or a
baby and give the primary custody to the
male the man the dad or it's actually a
really good point I just like if it's a
newborn
no I just have that question I just
answered the question it should be
default 50 50. it's half of the man's
genetics half of the woman's genetics
half of the man's chromosomes half of
the woman's chromosomes it's half their
baby it can't be well you know we're
gonna we're gonna give the mom the kid
until the kid's age two and then we're
going to introduce the dad no if the mom
wants to breastfeed that's fine and the
mom can breastfeed on her time and can
send bottles to the arguing with you
that it should be 50 50.
your girlfriend just asked if if the
father should have what did you say I'm
saying that if the that the mother
should not be the primary custody but
honestly the kids you're saying that no
one should say it's it shouldn't be 50
50. I'm saying the primary like look
what the person lit like the kid living
with the mom but honestly when it's 50
50 they're not live they're not
full-time at anyone's house they're
bouncing back and forth so and that's
what the California state law pushes for
your statement said your statement was
no one's saying that it shouldn't be 50
50 your girlfriend just said that that
it shouldn't and I agree with you it
should it should be 50 50. it should not
be where the mother just being a mother
gets primary physical custody of these
kids okay so so I agree with you I don't
agree with her like Father should have
equal right to these children they do
that their children
that's not that the man sitting next to
you Adam told you is that 90 eight
percent of the time women get primary
physical custody of these kids I know
what you're saying imagine if it was
vice versa imagine if it was vice versa
if women only got custody 10 of the time
we would be an uproar about absolutely
but you never hear about it because when
it comes to men like we're looking at
all the the reasons though like there
could be reasons to why that status
yeah there could be reasons to wear okay
did not want to be around maybe the
father can't be around us not a ton of
them yes nine out of ten wow that's
that's a bold statement I well that's
what I think
Madison what do you say I'm saying that
there's so many reasons to why the stat
like this percentage could be this High
did you know that I just saw an article
the other day that hooks are more likely
to get custody of their children
prostitutes Pearl that is such a great
point because every everybody just like
her everybody wants to to look at what
the problems are the what the man are
and assume that the mother is a good
mother I have represented so many shitty
mothers that still get custody of these
kids but everybody's like oh well 90 of
the time the moms get custody so there
must be a reason on the dad's side this
is what you just said no one looks at
the mother's side though and wonders why
is it if women are human beings sue if
if if if if if men can be poor fathers
then women can be poor mothers why is it
that even with women being poor mothers
they get custody 90 of the time yeah
right if you sit back and think about
this it doesn't make sense of course
there's a preference for women the men
are getting screwed over by them as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible